this is the JCPenney department store in
Hurst Texas unveiled in 2019 the
remodeled store includes style coaches
fitness classes in a coffee bar it
represents the latest strategy that
JCPenney has deployed in an effort to
draw in customers JC Penney rose to
prominence as a national retailer by
dressing the middle class but analysts
say the retailer's costly shifting
strategies have failed to attract the
modern middle class customer leading the
company to file for bankruptcy with so
many Americans staying home because of
the coronavirus crisis sales across the
retail industry have plummeted creating
an uncertain future for many retailers
here's how JCPenney fell from the top of
retail JCPenney was founded in CHEM imir
Wyoming in 1902 by James Cash Penney the
first store was named the Golden Rule
and catered to farmers by selling blue
jeans and other work where the retailer
changed its name to JC Penney and
expanded to locations across the United
States JC Penney was quality clothes
price they basically dressed the
middle-class and they had everything
from clothes for kids to career clothes
for women and men in 1958 it began
allowing customers to make purchases on
credit and in 1963 JC Penney released
its first catalog well they sort of came
up during the era when shopping malls
were populating the country they were
sought after by mall developers to be
anchors they developed these private
label brands like Arizona jeans and
forthing ttan that customers just loved
the retailer stock price rose throughout
the 1980s and 90s but with the rise of
fast fashion and e-commerce retailers
like JC Penney have faced problems in
recent decades cheekily retailers in the
middle and we're neither high nor low
found themselves you know in distress JC
Penney hired former Apple executive Ron
Johnson in 2011 as CEO Johnson scaled
bat promotions and discontinued private
brands he had run
retail stores and been very successful
making Apple you know a very hot place
to shop he's shifted to an everyday low
price strategy which sounds good in
theory but it turns out customers really
like deals then former Home Depot
executive Marvin Ellison took charge in
2015 he brought back appliances to the
store a product category JCPenney hadn't
sold since 1983 appliances you know it's
a whole different business it takes
different it's different distribution
it's different skills it's lower margin
and as Kennedy really focused on rolling
out appliances it took its eyes off
apparel which is where it makes the bulk
of its money between 2014 and 2018
JCPenney only had three profitable
quarters since Jill Sultan took the helm
in 2018 the brand has been trying to
implement changes like those in the
Hurst location unfortunately they
haven't really had enough time to see
what works and they don't really have
the money to roll this out you know on
mass its stock had been trading below $1
for long enough that the New York Stock
Exchange he notified the company that it
was at risk of being deleted and they
have been in talks with with creditors
but you know they were not able to reach
a deal before the crisis in March
JCPenney announced it would be closing
all of its stores in furloughing workers
in response to the corona virus outbreak
in the United States in April Fitch
downgraded the company's bond rating
which was already in junk territory and
soon after the company announced it
would skip an interest payment owed to
bondholders but you know all stores are
closed it's lost most of its revenue
what is the inventory gonna be worth
when they can actually get around to
selling it I mean there are a lot of
unknowns that just make the whole
process more difficult so that sort of
middle of the road department store has
really lost favor and you need to really
define who you are this sort of like
trying to be everything to everyone is
not a game you can play in today's world